un moment de sa vie chaque Français sera
millionnaire si si je vous assure un
Français travaille en moyenne 40 ans
profite de sa retraite pendant 20 ans
avant de mourir à 83 ans en partant de
ces chiffres combien gagnera tu pendant
toute ta vie on pourrait calculer ça à
partir de la moyenne des revenus des
Français
2340 euros net par mois mais ce chiffre
est biaisé par les mégaristes qui tirent
artificiellement se montant vers le haut
car oui quand Bill Gates entre dans une
salle on peut dire qu'en moyenne tout le
monde devient millionnaire en réalité
2340 euros il n'y a que 30% de la
population qui gagne ça ou plus vous le
voyez sur ce graphique où on a séparé
tous les Français en 10 paquets on
appelle ça des décils tous représentent
un niveau de revenu par exemple les 10%
des Français les plus pauvres gagnent
700 euros en moyenne 30% d'entre nous
gagnent moins que le SMIC et 12% des
Français vivent avec le salaire minimum
à l'autre bout du spectre les 10% des
Français les plus riches sont à plus de
4763 euros ça paraît correct mais le top
1% des Français
9030 euros en fait si on veut une bonne
estimation de ce que gagne les Français
il faut prendre le revenu médian soit le
centre de ce graphique 1790 euros par
mois la moitié des Français gagnent plus
l'autre moitié moins en travaillant 40
ans ça te fait 860000 euros au total à
ça tu ajoutes une retraite moyenne de
1340 € et un héritage médian de 70 000
euros au final la très grande majorité
des Français gagneront plus d'un million
d'euros au total de leur vie il y a de
grandes chances que tu en fasses partie
pour être honnête tu gagnes même un peu
plus que tu ne le penses car en France
il y a un salaire caché que tu ne vois
pas il t'invisible mais c'est bientôt
qu'il touche juste tu peux pas
l'utiliser ce sont les cotisations il y
a un salaire net c'est ce que tu touches
le brut lui inclut tes cotisations et le
réel c'est la somme totale versée par
ton employeur en France presque la
moitié de ce que tu touches n'est pas
directement pour toi imaginons que tu es
ingénieur que tu te mettes super bien
avec un petit salaire de député 7200
euros nets par mois ça c'est ce que tu
touches directement mais en réalité ton
entreprise tapé 9050 euros en brut et
12950 au total c'est ton salaire réel et
c'est pas fini car sur ton net tu as
l'impôt sur le revenu il te reste 5610
euros soit une répartition 43 pour toi
57 pour l'État enfin pour toi
indirectement on va détailler à noter
cosmique et au salaire médian la
répartition n'est pas la même là où ça
pique c'est quand tes chefs d'entreprise
disons que tu fais un t-shirt avec ta
tête dessus un mec l'adore et te
l'achète un million d'euros on va dire
que tu as pas de coup de production de
transport donc tout est à toi tu es
riche attends un peu enlève la TVA les
impôts sur les sociétés et sur tes
dividendes il te reste 411000 euros 290
000 si tu te verse ça en salaire de
patron et attends vu que tu repayes la
TVA sur tout ce que tu achètes en France
avec cet argent au final seul 35% des 1
million t'appartiennent vraiment
22% si tu le fais en salaire ouais entre
70 et 80% ont été redistribués à la
collectivité tu peux en être fier parce
que grâce à ça tu as la sécurité sociale
le chômage et la retraite contrairement
à une idée reçue c'est pas vraiment
gratuit vu que tu les payes dans tes
cotisations pour un salaire médian de
1790 euros tu vas payer par mois 100 €
de chômage 100 euros pour ta famille et
ta formation 640 euros de retraite et
260 euros de santé ça peut paraître
beaucoup mais qu'est-ce que ça donne
quand on compare aux États-Unis
contrairement à une idée reçue on paye
pas 40000 dollars l'accouchement enfin
si mais c'est remboursé la balle la
santé aussi est gratuite à condition
d'avoir une assurance qui coûte entre
200 et 500 dollars selon ton âge 1200
pour une famille salé un tout petit peu
moins pour l'ingénieur de tout à l'heure
qui paye plus de cotisations que le
salaire médian après un système
d'assurance privé c'est souvent plein de
soucis comme des clauses cachées ou des
franchises si tu as des enfants en plus
la facture explose le fait contraint à
cotisée ça évite les mauvais choix
individuels si Breaking Bad s'était
passé en France au Walter White aurait
juste eu à sortir sa carte vitale et
finito et justement puisqu'on parle de
lui il amassé des millions pour mettre
ses enfants à l'abri mais concrètement
combien faut-il amasser d'argent pour ne
plus jamais avoir à travailler en 60 ans
de vie d'adultes tu vas beaucoup
dépenser rien que pour te loger avec un
loyer de 700 euros par mois moyenne
c'est déjà 500.000 euros de perdu et à
côté il faudra te nourrir ta billets te
chauffer t'assurer le pire étant le prix
d'un enfant savez-vous combien vous avez
coûté à vos parents
5300 euros par an vêtement jouer
nourriture état de la chance l'école est
gratuite parce que sinon faudrait
rajouter les 8000 euros par an qui sont
pris en charge par l'État et attend ça
c'est quand tu es jeune une fois les
études supérieures commencées le budget
explose au total tu auras coûté 180000
euros à tes parents pense à les
remercier jusqu'à sa mort le français
moyen aura dépensé entre 1 et 2 millions
d'euros plus que tout ce que tu gagneras
seul ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui dans un
couple les deux conjoints doivent
absolument travailler pour espérer
survivre 2 millions d'euros ça serait
donc la somme qu'il faudrait réunir pour
pouvoir couler des jours heureux sur une
île pas vraiment en moyenne les Français
mettent de côté 280 euros par mois il
faudrait 600 ans pour atteindre les 2
millions réunir cette somme et donc
quasi impossible à moins d'utiliser le
pouvoir de la dette un principe
d'éducation financière que vous devriez
tous connaître et pour vous le prouver
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi Elon
Musk est l'homme le plus pauvre du monde
certes sa fortune est estimée à 288
milliards de dollars avec ça il pourrait
distribuer 4300 euros à chaque Français
ou 37 euros à chaque personne dans le
monde pour pouvoir les galets avec un
SMIC il faudrait pouvoir vivre 18
millions d'années évidemment tu
t'imagines bien qu'il est pas comme
Picsou et qui garde pas cette somme en
cage dans un énorme coffre-fort et même
s'il pouvait souffrir un yacht ou une
villa chaque jour jusqu'à la fin de sa
vie il a décidé de vivre avec le strict
minimum en réalité Elon Musk est
probablement l'humain le plus fauché de
l'histoire puisque tous ces comptes
bancaires sont dans le rouge avec une
dette de plus de 548 millions de dollars
minimum attendez un peu avant de le
plaindre c'est justement grâce à son
endettement qu'il est aussi riche et
l'un de musk possède 10% de Tesla sous
forme d'action grâce au succès de
l'entreprise leur valeur en Bourse a
triplée il pourrait les vendre et
ramasser un paquet de caches mais il
perdrait le pouvoir de son entreprise et
ferait chuter son cours il est donc
contraint de garder ses actions tous les
jours la fortune de muscle fluctue de
plusieurs millions à la hausse comme à
la baisse par exemple le 25 octobre 2021
il gagne 36 milliards en une journée un
record mais si demain Tesla se casse la
figure il perdra tout sans avoir jamais
vu la couleur de cet argent alors
comment fait-il pour financer ses
implants capillaires et l'éducation de
sa famille grâce à la dette il peut
s'endetter de façon presque illimitée
les banquiers savent qu'il n'a qu'à
vendre ses actions pour pouvoir les
rembourser faire ça énorme avantage aux
yeux des impôts et Elon Musk est un
pauvre criblé de dette et en tant que
PDG il a décidé de ne se verser aucun
salaire et en plus les actions Tesla ne
génèrent aucune dividende donc son
revenu officiel est de 0 il est dans le
dernier défile si je vous raconte tout
ça c'est qu'il y a une leçon en tirer
pas qu'il faille pour des impôts
payez-les mais plutôt qu'être endettés
n'est pas une honte c'est même l'outil
qu'utiliser riche pour devenir encore
plus riche vous voulez savoir comment
c'est le moment clé de cette vidéo celle
où je vous explique comment devenir
riche grâce aux mathématiques tous les
jours vous perdez de l'argent vous en
perdez à cause de l'inflation une
baguette en 2001 valait 66 centimes
aujourd'hui presque 1 euro en fait
chaque année l'argent que tu as sur ton
compte te permet d'acheter de moins en
moins de choses ce qui fait que
logiquement l'argent qui dort c'est de
l'argent gaspillé là en ce moment si tu
as touché un héritage que tu as 100000
euros sur ton compte avec l'inflation tu
vas perdre 6500 euros cette année alors
comment faire c'est là que les Mathé qui
interviennent avec deux grandes astuces
financières que vous devriez absolument
connaître la première c'est 4 endettés
c'est fantastique impossible d'acheter
un appartement en économisant si tu mets
200 euros de côté chaque mois il te
faudrait 80 ans pour espérer avoir un
petit studio parisien à 200000 € non ce
que tu dois faire c'est emprunter au
lieu de donner 700 € de loyer tous les
mois un propriétaire tu vas les donner à
la banque pour rembourser ton prêt et
dans 25 ans l'appartement sera 100% à
toi c'est magique mais il y a quand même
des limites en France ta capacité
d'emprunt est limitée à 35% de tes
revenus ce qui veut dire qu'avec un
revenu médian tu ne peux t'acheter qu'un
bien de 142.000 euros maximum voilà
pourquoi on achète en couple
généralement sachez-le il existe une
stratégie qui consiste à toujours
s'endetter au maximum légal attends
c'est un coup à finir ruiner avec les
huissiers aux fesses non si tu tendettes
pour acheter une télé écran plat oui pas
si tu fais des investissements avec cet
argent imaginons que tu as 100 000 euros
sur ton compte que tu dois acheter un
appartement au même prix acheter cash
serait une erreur mieux vaut emprunter à
2% pour acheter ta maison et investir
tes 100000 € à toi dans un placement à
6% oui oui paradoxalement on empruntant
tu peux gagner plus d'argent c'est ce
qu'on appelle un effet de levier mais
attention si tu rates ton investissement
et qui finit par te coûter plus cher que
ton crédit là bah c'est un effet Massu
un effet levier ça permet de faire des
choses magiques prenons la chaîne d'un
appartement que tu vas louer chaque mois
tu vas percevoir des loyers qui seront
supérieurs à ce que tu dois rendre
mensuellement ta banque genre tu touches
un loyer de 700 et tu rembourses 650 ce
qui est beau là-dedans c'est que c'est
700 euros de loyer bah ils vont
regénérer ta capacité d'emprunt les 35%
dont on parlait tout à l'heure avec ça
tu vas pouvoir réemprunter pour acheter
un autre appartement et recommencer à
l'infini c'est comme ça que certains se
sont construits des empires immobiliers
des centaines d'appartements qui louent
tout ça en partant de zéro en utilisant
les failles du système bancaire bon dans
les faits c'est un poil plus complexe il
y a l'apport les impôts les frais de et
des impondérables il suffit d'un loyer
un pays ou d'une grosse fuite d'eau et
tu pourras juste pas rembourser la
banque et là ben c'est les faits massues
et pour les locataires pas de panique ça
reste avantageux dans beaucoup de cas
déjà en tant qu'étudiant vous n'avez pas
de fiche de paie convenable pour
emprunter et acheter ne devient
intéressant que si vous restez au moins
trois ans au même endroit en dessous
vous risquez de perdre de l'argent à
cause des frais d'achat la deuxième
astuce financière dont je voulais vous
parler c'est celle queenstein surnommée
la huitième merveille du monde un
concept mathématique surpuissant les
intérêts composés imaginons tu mets 500
euros dans ton épargne tous les mois tu
touches des intérêts disons 2% comme le
livret A ça te fait gagner 76 centimes
par mois soyons honnêtes c'est pas ouf
sauf qu'au fil des mois les intérêts
vont eux-mêmes faire des intérêts qui
génèrent encore plus d'argent c'est
l'effet boule de neige la machine
s'emballe c'est une exponentielle en
mettant 500 euros par mois sur votre
épargne de vos 18 à 60 ans par exemple
sur un cérémonie à 5,9%, d'après vous
combien aurez-vous à la fin dans les
faits vous n'aurez versez que 250000
euros mais en ouvrant votre compte
surprise vous avez plus d'un million
d'euros une retraite de millionnaire la
règle est simple un euro aujourd'hui
dans 10 ans il en vaudra 2 dans 50 ans
il en voudra 30 c'est 1000 euros que tu
as cramé dans des skins lol si tu les
avais investi par exemple faudrait
possiblement 30 000 à ta retraite c'est
ça le pouvoir des intérêts composés mais
concrètement comment on fait ça sans se
prendre la tête moi c'est simple tous
les mois je mets 250 euros dans mon
assurance vie au money et 250 euros dans
un PEA un portefeuille d'action toujours
géré par Yomi c'est pour ça que je les
ai contactés moi-même pour cette vidéo
et le sponsorise pour moi c'est juste
les meilleurs leur cité beau simple à
utiliser et surtout il y a une
technologie derrière avec des
intelligences artificielles et les
gérants expérimentés à votre service
c'est littéralement le service de luxe
qui est normalement réservé aux
meilleurs clients des banques et ah ça
coûte très cher chez eux là grâce à
Internet est mis à disposition du grand
public pas de papier pas de frais
d'entrée et des commissions rikiki et
surtout vous avez le choix faire des
investissements classiques ou
écologiquement responsables avec un
paramétrage des risques selon dix
niveaux moi j'ai pris le niveau 9 parce
que je suis prêt à perdre un peu de cet
argent s'il économise portait vraiment
mal dans les 10 ans à venir oh là là
malheureux la dernière fois qu'on m'a
fait un conseil d'investissement c'était
un Ch'tis à Dubaï qui m'a scanner avec
sa crypto monnaie un flux voleur la
piraterie tu connais non yomoni c'est
connu il y a des pubs à la télé c'est
régulé de très près par l'Autorité des
marchés financiers et c'est multiré
compensées l'assurance vie commune en
53% des Français en ont une c'est un
placement très régulier même si bien sûr
tout investissement reste à risque même
acheter une maison demain elle peut
s'écrouler ou voir un crack immobilier
si vous êtes chaud vous pouvez ouvrir un
compte sur le site yomoni.fr et
commencez à investir l'essentiel c'est
de garder à l'esprit ces trois conseils
on ne met jamais tous ces œufs dans le
même panier du homony de l'immobilier un
peu un peu de bourse il y a plein de
blocs d'experts qui seront vous donner
la balance idéale 2 n'investissez que ce
que vous pouvez vous permettre de perdre
ne vous mettez jamais dans une situation
compliquée parce qu'un mec sur Internet
vous a dit que vous pourriez faire
fortune on sait jamais 3 ne prenez
jamais de décision sous la panique les
cris sont peur oui mais voyez plutôt
comme des opportunités comme les soldes
de la Bourse quand on regarde l'histoire
le temps long les crashs sont récurrents
et à chaque fois l'économie s'est
relevée non sans qu'au passage certains
profitent en rachetant des actions
vendues à perte sous la panique yomony
justement s'occupe de tout ça et vous
évite de faire des bêtises la morale de
cette vidéo c'est que finalement devenir
riche ne nécessite pas forcément de
monter une startup ou gagner au loto le
plus important c'est l'héritage et pas
celui de maison de Château non
l'héritage d'une éducation financière
avoir eu des parents qui vous ont aidé à
gérer votre argent très jeune des
stratégies d'investissement ces conseils
pour faire fructifier son épargne de se
transmettre souvent contre riches avec
Internet est notre audience on a voulu
vous donner ce que nos parents n'ont pas
fait en espérant que vous qui nous
regardez puissiez tous vivre dans
l'abondance pour vos futurs familles je
vous attends dans 20 ans en espérant que
ce soit pour nous remercier plutôt que
nous maudire pensez à vous abonner et à
liker cette vidéo allez les amis Ciao
[Musique]